je vais me tourner vers une
représentante de la librairie et à ma
grande surprise car je l'ignorais avant
de commencer cette émission c'est ma
libraire c'est ce qu'on appelle la
librairie de quartier pauvre c'est à
dire c'est une dénomination très noble
sénatrice de la vaissière qui tient mais
je vais le dire la librairie libre à
lire russe à mort à deux pas de chez moi
et c'est chez elle que je me fournis
dans ces objets délicieux c'est pas
gagné n'avait pas fiable me dira le
contraire alors quelle est la situation
dans la librairie aujourd'hui est ce que
vous avez réussi un peu à vous organiser
pendant ce confinement qui dure est
organisée c'est à dire qu'en fait on a
été assez surprise en ut on a annoncé le
confinement le 31 octobre
le vin le 30 octobre j'ai pu le jeudi ça
a été la follement on a travaillé comme
on ne travaille
deux jours avant noël ce qui prouve bien
qu effectivement c'est pas un commerce
essentiellement fin c'est quand même
nécessaire à on a mis en place le
système de kick and collect c'est
vraiment
[Musique]
moundir c'est juste pour dire que la
libre est encore ouverte qu'on est
encore vivant mais ça n'a rien à voir
avec ce qu'on peut faire
j'ai beaucoup défendu les librairies je
me suis quand même laisser dire par un
éditeur que les libraires avaient la
possibilité d'ouvrir au mois de mars et
que de leur propre chef
ils ont refusé de le faire et que du
coup c'est un décret qui a été presque
mécaniquement reconduit que vous êtes un
peu piégé non grata c'est vrai qu'il ya
des syndicats de libraires qui ont qui
nous ont effectivement inciter à fermer
on a réouvert justement en click and
collect pendant une quinzaine de jours
fin bon les les tout derniers jours de
bon en fait les gens étaient contents de
revenir c'est mais c'est pas ça
effectivement je dire ça ne rattrape pas
du tout le chiffre d'affaires personnes
nous ont fait à peu près 30% de moins de
chiffre d'affaires le mois de novembre
est le mois décembre est quand même le
plus gros mois de lanouaille j'ai
téléphoné à des collègues de bonlieu ils
disent ben nous on fait 90 % de moins
c'était à qui il ne travaille plus du
tout méchant il ya des librairies qui
sont bien placés et qui travaille
beaucoup avec du le mouvement des
personnes et qui dit nous on est quand
même entre 50 et 60% de moins et des
librairies du 11e et ça n'empêche pas le
président la république de poser sur sa
photo d'invertir avec un andré gide en
pléiade et les mémoires de de gaulle à
bursa mais ça on sacralise la
littérature mais au moment où elle vit
via maurice juste une chose quand même
que je voudrais répondre aux heures des
problèmes d'économie de survie parce que
je sais pas du tout si on va tenir en
janvier mais la question qui me
travaille c'est à dire qu'en fait on
fait effectivement du dépannage du click
and collect donc les gens viennent
chercher les grosses ventes les ventes
qui sont médiatisés les auteurs qui sont
effectivement reconnu et qu'on attend
c'est son pense à carrer on pense à
mauvignier on pense à des gens comme ça
qui effectivement
qu'on va vendre parce que les gens sont
venus les chercher et en même temps
c'était quand même un peu le rôle du
libraire c'est à dire tous les petits
éditeurs les autres les livres qu'on
connaît pas les auteurs qui sont des
premiers auteurs c'est terminé on leur
coupe complètement les jambes
il n'y a pas de conseils bien sûr nous
on est juste là pour faire ce que disait
que faisait pour les jouets la grande
surface des terres qu'on va chercher le
livre en rayon et on les donne sur le
trottoir mais en même temps
effectivement il y a des des gens de qui
travaillent sur internet ou dans les
réseaux sociaux soit bon je passe encore
le nommer voilà monsieur dit c'est pas
la peine
mais en fait eux qui profitent justement
de ses ventes
quand nous on en vend 200 et devant 300
milles fabre angers diack et c'est
toujours les mêmes ventes s qui a pas
une volonté du gouvernement de vouloir
absolument faire effectivement couper
l'herbe sur le pied à la pensée aux
nouveautés
je dire on al impression qu on a
beaucoup parlé de deux noms pourquoi
vous avez raison à kadima d'idée quand
même effarant
mais non mais le gouvernement je me suis
alors mais moi c'est lui non mais je ne
suis d'accord
des petits commerçants ne pas dire qu'il
faut mais il est effarant qu'au pays de
l'exception culturelle riche en culture
notre absolument pas dans l'équation
déconcerté mécanique est quelque chose
qui ne va pas et de tout ça sur eric le
mode essentiel in essentiel et déjà
vexatoires pour les gens à oui mais je
suis on est bien obligé de partir
d'éléments qui sont dans les pâtures
beaucoup patrice pour terminer là on
parle de la culture et on parle
effectivement de la liberté d'expression
on en a beaucoup parlé pour défendez des
événement absolument dramatique
mais il se trouve qu'au niveau de la
culture ont coupé l'herbe sous le pied
alors peut-être que le gouvernement ne
veut pas mais ça n'empêche que c'est en
fait ce qui se passe c'est qu'en fait au
couple a reçu sous le pied de tous les
gens qui pensent et qui pensent en avant
qui pense pas des choses qui sont
complètement inconnu et tous et qui vont
permettre effectivement de faire un
éditeur de faire un bon coup et vous
souhaitez annuel mâcon port privé
confinement avaient dit et je vous
demande de rester chez vous et de lire
bah ouais bah ouais mais charmant stop
non non c'est ainsi un problème de
économique mais c'est un problème
culturel